when this conversation comes up and and
you're with friends and you've got
Republicans in there you got Democrats
in there you got independence in there
you got those who don't give a [ __ ] in
there right they're just talking to each
other and we all have friends and family
when we're by ourselves talking uh you
know uh some will say well Pat you say
what you want but Donald Trump when he
was president there was no war nobody
thought about Isis you know Palestine
and Israel look at all the stuff that he
did and everybody was afraid that was
going to be World War III under Trump
but that never was a trending topic on
Twitter Etc et cetera look what Biden is
doing he's causing world war three we
can potentially go there and look how
much problems we're having on the way we
left Afghanistan and by the way these
are people some people that are saying
this are people on the left that are
saying this you know Matt Zeller former
CIA agent who you know on Brian Williams
talked about hey the way we left
Afghanistan that shouldn't been the
right way to leave there's a lot of
people that are not happy about the way
we've handled things under by the
administration and a lot that we're
hoping that a Biden would have been
somebody that would have been more
peaceful less warless issues but it
seems like every other day you turn on
the news there is some kind of issues
going on whether it's Afghanistan
whether it's Iran whether it's Ukraine
whether it's Russia you know so what do
you say to the people that say under
Trump U.S was more at peace and less
fear of war was there and under Biden
it's been constant fear of potential War
what do you say to those people
uh well I respectfully disagree
um the reality is in 2017 as soon as
Trump came to power he launched a
massive crisis with North Korea that
almost led to war
um and it's absurd I would argue to
blame uh Biden for Putin's uh aggressive
decision to invade Ukraine
um Putin has been planning this for some
time including during the Trump
Administration
so I think this is in Putin's lap he
wants to grab more land that doesn't
belong to him uh and the world has
appropriately stood up to that
aggression uh the United Nations General
Assembly just voted
overwhelmingly to condemn Russia's
annexation of Ukrainian land as illegal
under international law and the Biden
Administration has really done a
remarkable job in pulling the NATO
alliance together in a way Trump utterly
failed to do when Trump was president
got it I have a question yeah um just so
we're all clear would you reveal where
you lean politically are you on the left
or in the right are you more of a
moderate are you just a believer in
common sense are you just an educator
what would you reveal
so uh I regard myself as a political
Centrist but it is true that I have uh
served in the past in Democratic
administrations and have largely uh it
offered my advice primarily on the
Democratic side okay so does that
um negate you from having having
credibility
uh I don't think so I think in our
country we need to have bipartisan
cooperation on not only National
Security but a wide variety of things if
we want to have sustainable public
policy over time unfortunately in the
world that we have today our country is
so polarized that it we keep reversing
course on policy after policy every time
you know one party or another takes
power just just a question before we go
to Katie hoppings I got one question for
you we had do you remember Mr uh uh
Peter pry
yep okay we we had them on a couple
times uh and he rest in peace he just
passed away about a month ago a month
and a half ago two months ago just I
don't know if you knew that or not he
just passed away yeah yeah Peter did you
know Peter pry no but you just broke
that news oh yeah he just passed away
two months ago we had him on the podcast
twice twice in the span of a month and
then two months later he passed away
crazy uh uh
are you familiar with what his belief
system what the what what he believed uh
uh he viewed the nuclear threat that we
had did UNM speak regularly because I I
like what you just said right now where
Adam said do you lose credibility to say
what you're saying he said no you know
this is how America is we get to sit
there and debate and you know agree and
disagree and we get to say well I agree
with Professor Bunn I agree with Peter
pry how how different of a world view
did you have when it comes down to
nuclear threats from Peter Pride the
late Peter Pride
so I think somewhat different
um there are lots of different views and
in these uh areas Peter was uh
especially concerned I I would argue
um uh almost obsessively concerned about
one particular aspect of the nuclear
threat which is the possibility of uh a
hostile State uh detonating a nuclear
weapon up in space where it could create
a massive electromagnetic pulse that
would short out a lot of our electrical
systems over much of the United States
if it were a big enough bomb detonated
in the right place and Peter did a lot
of great work on uh elucidating that
threat but I would argue that's only one
of many nuclear threats that we face
got it thank you for that Katie
um so my question is about zelenski and
to what extent you think he's actually
an authentic or legitimate leader or
whether you think perhaps he is as I
believe
um an actor or a puppet in the sense
that he was an actor in rubbers and high
heels until relatively recently and now
we're supposed to believe he's Winston
Churchill so my question is about
zielinski and my second question is
given you say nuclear war is unlikely to
what extent do you think Americans
ordinary Americans Rust Belt Americans
really care about what's going on in
Ukraine to what extent do you think they
could find it on a map to what extent do
you think spending in excess of maybe a
billion or a trillion dollars in Ukraine
really matters to people who can't put
fuel in their car
okay so uh two questions
um I would argue zielinski has uh proven
to the surprise of many to be a
remarkable wartime leader and
partly I think his
um media experience in the past has
allowed him to sort of dominate the
information space within Ukraine in a
very clever uh way that has unified the
ukrainians much more than they ever were
in the decades leading up to this war so
I think Ukraine is uh lucky that they
happen to have elected this leader it is
somewhat uh hilarious for Putin to be
describing the government of Ukraine as
a bunch of Nazis when uh they elected by
a vote of something like 70 percent a
Jewish president uh zielinski
I do think you're absolutely right that
a lot of Americans don't really care
much about what happens in Ukraine but I
think they should because
the principle all that countries aren't
allowed to just invade their neighbors
and grab chunks of their land if that
principle goes away uh we're in a very
very dangerous world and that was the
principle that we all agreed to after
World War II and we want to avoid
getting back into situations where we're
fighting Wars like World War II I think
I think blocking Russia in Ukraine is
actually quite important to U.S national
security in the end
um and that's going to be playing out
over the course of the months and of
course there is an enormous difference
between a billion which we've already
spent more than that and a trillion
which is a thousand times a billion uh
which is there's no Prospect of spending
remotely that say those numbers again
what do you think we actually spent
uh well we've spent uh
several billion I think over 10 billion
at this point in uh military and
economic assistance uh to Ukraine it's
going to be uh expensive When The War is
Over uh for some combination of Ukraine
and the International Community as a
whole to rebuild the place because the
amount of damage that's been done is
just horrifying like a rebuilding plan
we were having a friendly debate over
here of how much money we actually spent
or sent to Ukraine uh some of us believe
it's in the billions the most believe
it's in the trillions it's do you have
an accurate number
it's not remotely close to the trillions
trillions is a really big number
but you just said it's 10 billion that
seems that seems very probably over 10
billion at this point it's around 70
billion it's around 70 billion give or
takes it's a lot of money that we've
spent I don't think that's correct but
well I don't have none of us agree on
anything that's what we need to know
right but we all agree it's billions
Katie we're not it's not trillions but
he says 10 he says 70 and I said 10 10
billion and 70 billion is a lot closer
together than one point I got a trillion
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here